wir sprechen jetzt live mit dem sprecher
der mccanns erste mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet aus london
clarence mitchell fans und howard es
fehlen
fühlen sie sind diesen verdächtigen in
deutschland danke dass sie müssen jetzt
sprechen sie sich sechs ihrer tochter
verantwortlich
in vilshofen juristisch
die eltern werden kann abgeschlossen ist
und ungefähr auf die partei ist normales
leben
die anderen beiden kinder zu
die eltern haben
verfolgen sie die wirklich müssen sie
sich selber stunden vor diesem ganzen
informationen
irgendwie sind nicht alles eigentlich
alle warten darauf von der polizei macht
die lage ist die britische polizei mit 7
1 und wirklich wichtigen entwicklung
nutzen schon viel info das bka und die
kommt ja öffentlich zu haben
ich werde ihn auch alles mitteilen
freunde und familien immer aber die
ganzen grad ist es möglich auch selber
schützen und darauf warten dass die
wahrheit
ihr sei mitgeteilt für ihn ist ein
erschütterndes immer noch als ein
einfacher unfall
wie reagieren die eltern auf diesen
unterschied dass es nicht zu sein
und wenn das wort mord verlangt wird ist
für mich das letzte das die familie
bösch sondern möchte ich krieg das keine
beweise dafür der hand hat und daher
auch die portugiesische polizei
danke dir einfach mit seinen athleten
deswegen warten von der polizei nicht
die polizei und diese möchte ja auch
nicht bis nicht sprechen
was auch immer die gründe für diese
erklärung
aber die eltern sind sich ganz sicher
dass die polizei die wahrheit
herausfinden wird